foreign
happy Friday I am Jimmy phela in from
Greg so let's welcome tonight's guest
let's do this here we go
[Applause]
he's been behind more bars than a
recidivist felon host of Bar Rescue on
the Paramount Network John Taffer there
it is
he is so Sage it is hard to disengage
novelist the literary critic Walter Kern
in the house
and she puts the fun in Dysfunctional
Fox News contributor captive there it is
okay before we get to some news stories
it is Friday so it's time for this
[Music]
leftovers hmm
it's leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week like Greg does it's
my first time reading these by the way
who thought it was a good idea to let a
community college guy read on National
Television
buckle up kids here we go
a white activist named Evita Sarah Swati
was accused of cultural appropriation
after pretending to be Arab South Asian
and Latin if found guilty shall be sent
where all people who faked their
ethnicity go to the Massachusetts Senate
good job team Tiger Woods was in hot
water this week for giving fellow golfer
Justin Thomas a tampon
Woods has apologized saying he confused
Justin Thomas with Leah Thomas
[Laughter]
which by the way is entirely possible
because Leah Thomas still has her golf
balls
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good night everybody
a lawsuit reveals that Jeffrey Epstein's
emails to a banking executive used
Disney princesses as code names this is
noteworthy because Epstein previously
used musical notes as code names but he
never chose anything other than a minor
oh wow
that's funny you by the way everyone
hates Jeffrey Epstein but the clintons
always said he was a great hang
I'm not messing around folks
Washington State University is
threatening to withhold a student's
diploma because she owes a one cent
balance
and everybody knows if you go to a
liberal College these days you have to
have no sense
during a press briefing Thursday White
House Press Secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre
mistakenly called President Biden
President Obama
Don Lemon says this is what happens when
you hire a woman Pastor Prime
by the way if you wonder ing Karine
Jean-Pierre is 48 which is the same age
as kamala's IQ
um
speaking of Don Lemon he returned to the
airwaves this week the incredible part
is that lemon was off the air for three
shows but he wound up being seen by the
same amount of people if he had remained
on the air
foreign
Poland President Biden says U.S support
for Ukraine will not waver when asked if
he believed Biden zielinski said well I
did until I saw him try to get back on
the plane
but military experts say Russia should
still be careful because if Joe can do
half as much damage to Russia as he's
done to America Russia is toast
California is expected to get hit with
its first snowfall since 1989 this
weekend in fact the weather has gotten
so cold Gavin Newsom is advising
Californians to go poop indoors
[Laughter]
but the guy you have to worry about is
Jimmy Kimmel because even when it's warm
out his ratings are still experiencing
shrinkage you know
and in other weather news a rare
February tornado hit New Jersey this
week local officials at crawling it
Jersey's biggest disaster since 2009.
that's funny
by the way the reason comedians always
insult the cast of the Jersey Shore is
we don't want to insult the actual
citizens of Jersey and then wind up
getting like a thousand poorly spelled
hate males
I'm kidding is anyone from Jersey here
oh my God I'll speak slower I had no
idea
back it up and finally cocaine bear
opening up in theaters this week but
critics were disappointed to learn that
the coked up attacker was actually just
a guy in a bear suit
all right let's do the damn show here we
go here we go can she be the replacement
for the man who campaigned in his
basement self-help Guru Marianne
Williamson is entering the 2024
Democratic primary for president and
unlike Joe Biden she can pronounce all
her platitudes on Thursday America's
favorite Avon lady spilled the organic
beans to Northwestern University student
newspaper she didn't want to do it with
an outlet with limited exposure like CNN
she says she says she wouldn't be
running for president if she didn't
believe she could contribute to
harnessing the collective sensibility
she feels is our greatest hope at this
time how great is weed by the way uh
seeing as how Biden's greatest hope at
this time is a martian Invasion maybe
wacky ate Marianne is on to something
you remember Marianne ran for the White
House in 2020 on a platform of creating
a department of peace and Doling out 100
billion in reparations also part of her
platform free-flying brooms for everyone
[Laughter]
Maybe This Time those ideas will stick
but only if her dream catchers turned on
and by the way it was one year ago when
she and yours truly got into a bit of a
conversation right on this very show hit
it girl
I'll start with Stacey Abrams this has
nothing to do with masks this has
nothing to do with the photo op it's the
politics of distraction let's talk about
a mistake she did at a photo op so that
people will not listen to the important
things she's trying to say to the people
of Georgia can I just jump in here
though yes what she's demonstrating
there is a very callous indifference to
Children masking children is child abuse
people are not even looking at that as
mad about hypocrisy as they are is the
fact that there are kids and masks in
the background that shouldn't be I'll
give you that it's not a campaign I'll
give you that oh no you did Marianne
dude she couldn't even take on a cabbie
I had more people successfully argue the
route to Laguardia
[Laughter]
but then again how hard could it be to
run against a president who can't walk
my advice Marianne keep the Jasmine
incense burning and not just for good
luck Joe just made an executive order in
his pants
Captain if I go right to you you and I
spend some time with Marianne Williamson
on this show we both kind of thought she
was nuts that being said
don't you feel like it's time for Biden
to step aside for somebody younger like
Moses
a lot to say about Marianne Williamson
because when she was on I mean her voice
yeah
like is a comforting presence I would
pay a very Hefty monthly fee for any
time I'm freaking out just be able to
call her and have her be like you're
okay
[Laughter]
I didn't do worse than I think she could
do a little better in some ways like I
think she would go to East Palestine
yeah it would probably be because she
thought that bringing healing crystals
there would solve
but she would go and the department of
peace is not the worst idea because I
mean our Department of Defense I think
we should go back to it being that
instead of the Department of ooh war is
making me money
thank you thank you
Scott Benson I want to ask you a
strategic question
um she's launching her campaign at 2PM
on a Saturday is there a more less
relevant time slot I mean other than 8
P.M on CNN is there a less relevant time
slot well and she apparently made the
announcement to Northwestern
University's student newspaper which is
my alma Mater's oh get out yeah go Cavs
that's an excellent choice on her part a
strange one she makes a lot of those I
will say to Kat's point and watching the
fat the flashback clip of that what is
her accent it is totally indecipherable
it's a bizarre accent and yet listening
to her for just about 15 seconds made me
this close to joining whatever culture
sign me up where do I sign how much
money does it cost it's actually
somewhat disturbing here it is take the
money uh John I will ask you this uh
I've always said that Joe Biden would
make a great Walmart greeter if you
didn't mind being welcome to Target okay
three guys I was coming I had a question
I had a question
I'm sorry I'm so good at this I had a
question stick with me um would you hire
Joe Biden at the age he's at to run one
of your bars no I would not I would
maybe need to walk one of my bars
certainly not to run one of them no I
mean the fact is he's stiff and he's
going to get angry at everybody all the
time that's true right somebody's going
to say to me I've been drinking he's
gonna you don't need a drink
yeah the worst part of that would be you
give him money for the Jukebox and he
sends it to Ukraine
[Applause]
Joe Biden is actually like the angry old
guy at the bar making up stories about
his life yeah he is that's his actual
role in this I'm not certain I would sit
a young girl next to him either hey
except they'd be like you've had enough
sir and he'd be like I haven't had
anything
doesn't remember what I had a drink
before yeah that's funny uh Walter I'm
gonna ask you this Marianne Williams
getting into the race does this change
your Calculus as a guy who's been openly
supportive of Kanye and everything he
says Ah
well I I
don't even know how to decipher that
uh but you know I think you should
challenge him to a debate in the Lotus
position
[Laughter]
she'll be able to win without speaking a
word you know he'll never get in the
Lotus position if he does he'll never
get out of it
but but I take her candidacy seriously
um because if she splits the yoga vote
there's really no way for Biden to win
and secondly everybody's talking about
how Charming she is and how seductive
her voice is I found it horribly grating
and annoying myself
it depends on who she's channeling us
but uh I I think that she makes him look
about 10 years older than he is which is
a huge accomplishment
and I'm sorry I asked you a weird
question I'm trying to bridge a 300
Point IQ gap between you and me right
now
I'll help you because I I feel stupid
sitting next to cat you know
yeah but
let me ask you this though uh because we
do bag on Biden but let's also give him
credit for the powerful words he's
inspired the country with who could
forget the end of the State of the Union
when he did say now is the time to
choose Unity over schmerged
I mean would you dare
[Laughter]
it really makes you think it really
makes you think uh here's a question on
a serious note about Joe Biden as we're
all like our job is to at least my job
is to be a political analyst and is he
going to run or is this guaranteed is
that man seriously going to be our
president for six more years no is that
a realistic thing that's the question
that he and his family I think have to
figure out first speaking as an American
2024 is Hunter's blood alcohol content
right now
before we go Greg will be on Bill
Maher's Club random podcast this Sunday
wow I didn't get that invite uh the
episode drops at 9pm Eastern go to
youtube.com
clubrandompodcast it'll also be
available on all major podcast platforms
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else